[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys wels
heute gibt ein italienisches weihnachts
rezept also eigentlich ein italienisches
weihnachts rezept aber ein italienisches
rezept und bei uns gibt es jetzt zu
weihnachten immer zu weihnachten genau
wir machen oder ich mache besser gesagt
cantuccini uns war das ein italienisches
gebäck was aber das ganze jahr über
gegessen wird
das wird wie zwieback zwei wolke packen
und es kommt aus italienischen provinz
prato aus der nähe von florenz
genau ja und es ist wirklich super
einfach vor allem finde ich ganz toll
weil es nicht so süß ist und es passt
perfekt zu einem espresso oder zu einer
tasse tee
ich hab zum wein wird oft gegessen ein
hauch von süße und ich finde es von der
zuckermenge wirklich ideal ist wirklich
nicht zu süß aber grad so süß also
wirklich super ihr braucht nur ganz
wenige zutaten und man kann dann
individuell verarbeiten und auch
variieren
ich habe jetzt hier einmal die
klassische variante mit mandeln und mit
bisschen strom zahlen abwägt und dann
habe ich noch eine dunkle variante mit
schoko kaffee und sa 10 gemacht richtig
gut aber ich sage euch am ende auch noch
mit was ihr das noch verfeinern können
wir starten jetzt gleich mal mit den
zutaten und die stellt kurz vor
für den teig brauche ich 500 gramm mehl
200 eine prise salz 50 gramm butter
etwas ein extrakt zwei teelöffel
backpulver und vier eier und dann
brauche ich noch 200 gramm gestifteter
mandeln 200 gramm ganze mandeln oder
pistazien zum beispiel und nach belieben
eine unbehandelte zitrone etwas
kakaopulver und vier esslöffel
flüssigkeit und zwar könnt ihr
teilnehmen amaretto zum beispiel nicht
wirklich supergut in cantuccini etwas
kaffee liköre oder irgendwas anderes
oder auch nur milch zum beispiel
jedenfalls könnt ihr mit der flüssigkeit
auch so ein bisschen den geschmack
bestimmen ob jetzt werde ich aber zuerst
mal die grund teig zubereiten und dafür
kommen jetzt die zutaten einfach alle in
die küchenmaschine also mehl zucker
das alles marille extrakt natürlich ganz
wichtig backpulver und auch gleich wie
butter die darf auch gerne schon ein
bisschen weich sein muss ja auch nicht
die verteilt sich gleich ganz gut
und das wird jetzt alles schön verrührt
[Musik]
ich werde ihn zeigt und gleich halbieren
und einmal eine helle variante mit
mandeln machen und einmal eine dunkle
schoko café variante
[Musik]
ich werde den teig jetzt halb ihr euch
zu zeigen wie man wie zwei verschiedenen
varianten machen kann
aber falls ihr nur eine variante macht
und könnte jetzt hier an der stelle
einfach normal weitermachen
jetzt ist natürlich noch nicht klebrig
weil ich noch keine flüssigkeit drin hab
einfach kontrollieren
eine hälfte geht wieder zurück die
anderen die andere schüssel und jetzt
mache ich hier erst mal die helle
variante und gebe jetzt zwei esslöffel
flüssigkeit dazu da geht zum beispiel
auch ganz guten mandl zero dann etwas
zitronenschale abrieb
[Musik]
400 g gehackte man so also gestiftet und
auch die 100 gramm ganzen mandeln und
berührt das nicht ganz gut dass jetzt
ganz kurz
[Musik]
erste tag ist jetzt schon auf fertig und
er darf jetzt auch so ein bisschen
klebrig sein und dann müsste dann
erstmal rein riechen weil so wie sie
jetzt riechen so schmecken sie dann auch
unterricht mit gut die mandeln und auch
die zitronenschale raus
gut geld aber jetzt wird gleich noch
besser für den buch nämlich er bekommt
nämlich die cantuccini mit schoko kaffee
und pistazien und dafür muss ich jetzt
erst mal einen espresso hinten kurz raus
lassen
hierzu nämlich den anderen tag also den
neutralen teig da kommen jetzt zwei
esslöffel espresso rein
für mich spielt übrigens gut mit vanille
extrakt hier kommen noch stadien die
gestifteten mandeln und zwei esslöffel
kakaopulver rein
potsdam habe ich meine zweite variante
[Musik]
wenn ihr merkt ihr mich benötigt wegen
dem kakaopulver noch ein bisschen mehr
ist so einfach noch bester film
[Musik]
ich wähle ich meine arbeitsweise ganz
gut und der teig kann auch sofort
weiterverarbeitet werden und arbeitet er
mit der hellen hälfte und teile den teig
jetzt in sechs portionen 1
[Musik]
und diese teile werden jetzt zu langen
rollen geformt
[Musik]
deswegen ist auch ganz wichtig dass der
teig schön feucht ist damit diese rollen
dann einfach nicht zerbrechen sollte
dürfen dann ungefähr 25 cm lang sein und
kommen dann gleich schon auf ein
vorbereitetes backblech
das mehl bisschen abschütteln
mit genug abstand aufs blech legen weil
die teile jetzt gleich noch ein bisschen
auseinander laufen
[Musik]
und das was ich jetzt verwende ist mein
eigenes paket ich das selber fläche dass
ganz viele kleine löcher und zwar bewegt
ist dass man die teile dann viel
gleichmäßiger durch backen kann und vor
allem bugs gibt werk viel schneller und
ihr könnt es hier außen auch an den
griffen verstellen das passt passt in
jeden backofen rein
[Musik]
die kante chili werden jetzt erst einmal
im backofen bei 190 grad ober unterhitze
für elf bis 13 minuten vorgebacken und
nachdem vor backen werde ich es zurecht
schneiden und dann nochmal nach wacken
nachdem vor backen sehen die cantuccini
stangen jetzt so aus und jetzt könnt ihr
noch warm in scheiben schneiden am
besten diagonal dass sie dem am besten
aus und etwa einen zentimeter breit und
dann lege ich sie wieder aufs blech aber
wieder schnittkante nach oben und so
können sie dann nochmal geröstet werden
für etwa neun bis zehn minuten da schaut
er einfach nach der farbe und danach was
ich da abkühlen und dann darf der monat
gleich probieren
[Musik]
um
die canto chinesin jetzt abgekühlt und
ich habe sie in so kleinen döschen drin
und die halten auch wirklich sehr lange
eben dadurch dass sie zwei mal gebacken
sind so kann man sie haltbar machen und
du darfst jetzt mal probieren
wirklich die halten sich häufig über
monate hinweg aber eigentlich hatten sie
nicht so lange weil sie ist doch schnell
ausgeführter zu erden und ich mache
normalerweise also wenn ich die mal
mache mache ich gleich die menge mit
zwei oder drei kilo weil es einfach
super schnell geht und dann habe ich
halt in so einem riesigen schüssel und
diese ganzen keksdosen sind alle voll
mit cantuccini jetzt probier doch mal
kann auch um das ganze noch ein bisschen
weihnachtliche seinerzeit ja man kann es
uns bisher weihnachtlicher zu machen
auch zimt reingeben sternanis kardamom
also ganz viele weihnachtliche gewürze
oder auch gern mal was richtig ist wie
zum beispiel cranberries mit rein geben
ich glaube stern an sich auch als ich
mag beide varianten
ich werde mich so serviert kannst du es
zeigen richtig gut aus einfach so um es
besser in kambodscha cantuccini dazu von
lecker ist ein paar verpacken und an
meiner schwester schicken die findet
sich so lecker und weil sie sich den
namen cantuccini net merken konnte sagen
die immer berlusconi die sally packt
wieder ihren fans coni ja also ich finde
das genie super wenn ihr zum beispiel
ein kleines geschenk machen wollten
mitbringsel könnte die backen schön
verpacken in so einem test mädchen mit
einer schleife drum herum und dann habt
ihr ein schönes mitbringsel so extrem
teuer kandidieren dabei setzte sich
irgendwas nicht verwandeln
deshalb womöglich teuer
ja bist du jetzt weiter philosophieren
noch ein bisschen herum und mekka über
den preis der pistazien für den ich
nichts kann und wenn ihr das rezept nach
machen wollten geht gerne auf sell ist
block data stets noch mal ganz genau und
ich empfehle euch wirklich dieses rezept
nachts machen es ist wirklich super
lecker super einfach mit wenigen zutaten
und schmeckt auch noch haben dieses jahr
übrigens pistazien im angebot beim
juwelier bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]